today's topic the comment we often get
is that mean preacher biased against
women
and what i would say to that is uh yes
we are
yeah you're super biased against women
yes me too hashtag
i as well i want to get demonetized i
just said hashtag
true but you know why we're biased
against women
because that's who we date
that's the experiences that we have you
see i was working for a company that was
um
i was working collections for a company
for a uh
phone company and i really thought
people didn't like that company
i was biased because that's the
experience that i had
i was dealing with unhappy customers
my vision was that that company was
doing bad
but my department was doing with
was dealing with customers that don't
pay so i'm gonna
of course have an amount of experiences
with people
that are bad customers so
when you're introsexual and you're male
and you date women
your experiences are gonna be with that
i can comment on experiences that women
have
but only as a listener and not as
someone that that
happened so i don't know how it feels to
be like that
i can have empathy but i i can't
fully feel how it is you definitely give
me whitney houston vibes
well yeah well you know i'm more of a
shocker cam person you know
i'm every woman but at the end of the
day
i still can't feel like a woman she's
not twin
so i'm gonna say this about this right
we all have our biases and if you don't
know what the definition of bias it's a
towards it's um something that may
encourage one form of conclusion against
another right it's a tendency
people over the last sixty seven years
have kind of taken the word in means
that
it's inherently bad not all biases are
bad biases are normal and we all have
them
whether you're a scientist a toddler or
whatever
you have biases towards your family you
have biases towards people from your
community you have biases towards people
of your gender people from your
university versus other universities
we all have these right and so it's
important to acknowledge that we are
biased
i don't know what it's like to date man
some of you are surprised i thought you
was getting
nah i don't know so a lot of the
intricacies of what ladies are dealing
with and some of their struggles aren't
going to be voiced by
because most of what we speak on this
channel is generally either from like
most of it's from like a it's a has a
visceral basis
meaning it's born from experiences we
had or things that we witness or hear
that we
hear our friends saying if most of our
friends are men then that's what we're
gonna also assimilate a lot of right so
the nuances of the female experience i'm
just not gonna know but
you know the idea of walking home late
at night and feeling like
extremely unsafe right the idea of like
being around a group of dudes
like the way women feel like unsafe i'm
not gonna know i can
sympathize but i'll never be able to
empathize with your experience because i
don't know what it's like to walk
through life
and to be sexualized that way i don't
understand but i can sympathize and
listen
but that's not going to make for great
content right unless i want to be a
derrick jackson and pretend
and be a liar i can sympathize and be
like all right let me hear your
experience
if you come to this channel understand
you're getting something that is trying
to be objective as much as possible but
there's going to be some element of
subjectivity there's going to be some
element of bias involved
and if you're not enjoying that go hear
a female voice who echoes your thoughts
but on things that are gendered yeah
we're going to speak on it from a
certain perspective
even on race relations i acknowledge
that we got biases
because i don't know what it's like to
walk through life as a white person but
i have had experiences that have been
based on race that
affected me as a black person i don't
know what it's like to walk through life
as an asian person or a latino
right it's different i don't know what
it's like to walk through life as a
short person
but i did make one video on hiatus and
where i try to sympathize with their
experience
and you're gonna find some videos on
this challenge on the on this channel
that
whenever we see a guy doing some dumb
stuff
we call him out we try so we do that as
well
but yeah no with the same energy no we
don't because we don't have that same
energy
that's not for us to do that like abby
said
go find a channel that resonates with
whatever you're thinking but whenever
we're gonna see something that is
blatantly
stupid from a guy we're gonna call it
out yeah we're gonna call
trust me we're gonna call we've been
doing that we are doing that
we're going to keep on doing that but of
course our experiences
are more based on what we live yeah and
that's that
even our fans are buying our fans
because they have you know some kind of
link with us we'll sometimes
ignore things that would send crap i've
had fans come up like y'all are never
wrong i'm like what
i think i'm wrong sometimes yes how do
you think that
i look back on the videos and i'm like
oh yes
yeah we need to fix that so it's okay
to acknowledge these biases but we have
a responsibility to try to mitigate it
as much as possible
as to not pollute the waters but it's
impossible to get rid of all our biases
it's impossible
and i will never come a time where a
woman is going to tell me her dating
experience
and i'm going to feel as viscerally
strong as when i do when i hear a male
because i know what it's like to be a
dude and go up to a girl and get
rejected
so when i feel that type of like damn
it's because i've been through that so i
can empathize
of course it's gonna look and sound
different so i always find it funny when
people like you guys have biases
see i'm like yeah probably i believe it
i'm not i'm not immune to the idea that
i have blind spots i'm well aware
i just try to be aware of those blind
spots and try to mitigate it but that's
all
i can't get rid of them completely
nobody has 360 vision
that's why you got people around you to
help you out that's why i have women i
talk to to
get some perspective sometimes right
that's why you need people
because we can't look everywhere all the
time can't be awake all day long you
need somebody else to take the night
shift
if you took the day shift working with
preach provides me that perspective that
i don't get sometimes
you know you guys hear me talk about
marriage a lot of i learned from preach
a lot that i learned from literature
why because he's my eyes and places i
can't be so
lean on each other to work through some
of his bias but understand you can't get
rid of it and you're not a terrible
person for having it
but it's important for you to
acknowledge it that is your
responsibility
what you think um we said what we said
yeah but what do you have to say because
they feel like you got more to say
you're stupid no i just could tell i
looked at priest's eyes and i could tell
he was about to say something and no i
really had nothing else to say you said
what you said
i'm not going to repeat it either yeah
but it's not like you're a grown man
like listen
you got more to say this is your chance
what kind of your [ __ ]
forgot it here what's the bias that
you've had other than your workspace any
devices that you all had i'm pretty sure
i did
i mean work experiences being um
yeah i'm pretty sure i have genders
race was the difference between vices
and
what was it uh no pius can definitely
overlap with prejudice if that's yes
they could overlap i used to have a bike
against blind people
that's what i told you about before but
yeah prejudice you know i was just
looking at a
blonde person i'm like they must be
stupid because and all that stuff what
is the bias becomes
a prejudice is the same thing to me
sometimes
can be biases aren't inherently that
because let me give you an example
you being by story is your family
member's word it's not prejudice
no it's from live experience exactly
stress some biases are natural and they
make sense and they don't have to air
that doesn't mean that you have some
prejudice i certainly do it doesn't mean
that we have some biases that are bad we
certainly do yeah but not all biases are
created equal
you know it's like you're going to trust
your child or are you going to trust a
stranger a lot of people are going to
stress straight
just stranger because they got [ __ ] up
relationships
but you see what i'm saying most people
are good like my child would never
[ __ ] we got him on camera no he would
never miss we got dna
of him inside the person no he went okay
[ __ ] he's killing someone right now
no it's like what do you want me to do
biases that's not biases as
being blatantly blind and some people
will look at them like that's what a mom
supposed to do
yup biases have your back no matter what
so if you have a a married couple you
don't want her to have your back no
matter what yeah
that's what i'm saying bonnie inclined
body and quiet that's right y'all both
go to chip
so it's just important to have she ain't
going to jail my ass going to jail alone
i'ma just send her and i'm just sending
her letters but i still love you baby
while i'm piping somebody else
but you know what time it is let us know
what you guys think in the comments
below what are some of your buy biases
how do you guys feel about them
let's talk
[Applause]
[Music]
oh